- I'm back with our Ready to Rock hour.
(upbeat rock music)
(laughter)
Okay.
We've got legendary drummer Sheila E,
sitting in with the band y'all.
Give it up!
(applause)
Yes.
My next guest is another
legendary woman of rock.
She's won two Grammys,
and an Academy Award for her music.
During the pandemic,
she created a concert streaming service,
to bring live music to all of us at home.
It's called Etheridge TV.
Give it up for Melissa Etheridge! (claps)
(upbeat rock music)
(applause)
- Hi there.
- What's up.
I love your rock and roll room.
Your whole vibe right now.
(laughter)
- That's what we're doing.
This is Etheridge TV.
My wife and I put this together.
We're in our garage.
We call ourselves two moms in a garage.
And we, you know, put it all together,
during kind of a healing
time that we needed.
And this is our vibe.
- Dude, your garage is way
cooler than mine. (laughs)
(laughter)
(laughs) I'm like, I need,
I have like, garage
envy right now. (laughs)
(laughter)
I have like a Christmas
tree and some boxes.
(laughs) I was like,
So, I actually sang, "I'm The Only One"
for one of our karaokes last year.
I love singing your music,
because I get to just wail.
It's just such a freeing thing.
Listen, do you know Sheila E?
She's actually sitting in with us today.
Y'all know each other?
- I do. Sheila, wow!
- Hi Melissa!
I miss you!
- I miss you!
We need to rock soon.
Come on!
- I know. Let's go!
I'm coming over.
(laughter)
- Like this connection.
In weird COVID times, over screens.
I like it.
(laughter)
So, well, today is
dedicated to rock and roll.
And we've asked Jon Bon Jovi earlier,
what defines rock music for you?
- Well to me, rock and
roll has always been,
the music that we aren't
supposed to listen to as youth.
You know, it was,
it started with being, you know,
it's very sexual in nature.
It's about the taboos,
and it's about breaking the social norms.
And it's,
if you watch how rock and roll
sort of changed over time,
and we sort of changed over time.
Now, I consider your hip hop and rap,
sort of rock and roll now,
because it's the music that
you don't want your kids to
listen to, you know. (laughs)
- Yeah. (laughs)
So you,
you're such a mom.
So who were your musical
inspirations growing up?
Who were people you weren't
supposed to listen to,
and you wanted to become. (laughs)
- Right. (laughs)
Well, Bruce Springsteen.
You know, Bruce Springsteen was,
he just seemed to have the answers for me,
as far as rock and roll,
you know, was going.
I probably ended up somewhere between
Janis Joplin and Bruce
Springsteen, you know. (laughs)
- Oh my God.
I remember that time,
I think it was on the Grammys,
and you covered "Piece of My Heart"
Holy moly.
I was like,
so, I kind of wanted to quit.
(laughs) 'Cause I was like, well,
(laughter)
never gonna do anything like that.
Like, it was just,
it was amazing.
And it just was one of those times,
I feel like when,
we all love singing,
we all are performing,
but there's times when like,
you don't even remember what happened,
and you become the vessel
for something so much
bigger than yourself.
And that just felt like
that to me watching it.
- It was a very healing moment for me.
I was bald from chemotherapy.
I had to,
I had gone through that,
and it was my first time on stage,
or even in front of people.
I hadn't even been in crowds.
I was still doing radiation treatments.
And it meant a lot to me to get up.
And it was a big changing
moment in my life.
I, it's kind of before
that Grammys and after,
is kind of my musical career. (laughs)
- Yeah.
- And, yeah that was it.
That was one of my top
five moments ever. (laughs)
- Oh my God.
Well, that's so funny,
'cause literally we have
shared the stage before,
and I was freaking out.
Putting my best Meryl Streep on,
acting like I was like, totally fine.
- Yeah, oh it's so sweet.
And it's very important to me,
as I've gone through this, my career,
to really reach out to the
women who are coming up,
and making a name.
And you were just hitting your stride.
You were really doing great.
And you know,
you also, hold that sort
of rock and roll torch,
but also you are just
a down to earth person.
- Oh, thank you.
That means a lot coming from you.
I know,
I mean, it's been a difficult
year for me personally.
It's been a difficult
year for a lot of people.
And I know as well for you.
So how do you get there?
Does music help you?
- Absolutely.
The moment I realized we
were going into lockdown,
that's when I started
these concerts from home.
And I started them,
first, we were just in
our office back there,
with like one little camera,
one, not, you know, my phone,
and going on Facebook.
Do that every day.
And I would have gone longer,
but my son passed away.
Lost him to opioid addiction in may.
And that was when I,
my wife and I decided
we're gonna come out here,
to our garage.
We're going to build a
studio that we can stream in,
like a real studio.
And we created Etheridge TV,
where three nights a week,
Tuesdays, Thursdays, Saturdays,
I do music.
I just finished a show,
a cover show about
Stevie wonder, you know.
And so,
and it's a subscription service.
You go, Melissa,
Etheridge TV,
etheridgetv.com
subscribe, 50 bucks a month,
and you get 25 shows or what I, yeah.
25 shows, that's it.
- Wow!
That's a lot!
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like, you're working hard.
That's a lot of work.
(laughter)
- Absolutely. You know what?
It keeps me sane, it
keeps me out of trouble,
and I'm playing music, and
I'm actually getting better.
I've got, you know, guitars and pianos,
and everything in here, and I'm just--
- I love that you just
said, you're getting better.
And you are a legend. (laughs)
(laughter)
I'm getting better. (laughs)
- It's important.
It's important to keep learning.
- Yes, of course.
- And I learned all about streaming,
and cameras and everything.
- No, of course, of course.
Well, we have a young girl,
aspiring to achieve everything you have.
She is remarkable.
I mean, she's super talented.
So, I was wondering will
you help us surprise her?
- Absolutely.
- Okay, awesome, awesome. Okay.
Well, we're gonna take
you off Skype for a bit,
so she doesn't know you're here,
then we're gonna bring you back,
right at the right moment, alright?
- Got you. I'll be right here.